I want to start with congratulations on
this movie oh oh yes I didn't I thought
something new happened no no wow I
uncomfortably laughed many times good I
it was very yeah I'm going to say it
like that
um so for I like throwing this question
to a lot of people at the beginning yeah
if you've done a lot of cool different
projects if someone has actually never
seen anything you've done what is the
first thing you'd like them watching and
why oh
uh I would say Roxanne Roxanne uh I
think that film
highlights the black single mother
experience and it's one of my grittier
roles
I wear um
it was really this internal journey of a
woman trying to raise her children
living in the projects and in Queens you
have missing you people the best man the
Final Chapter yeah coming out all within
you know very close together when did
you actually decide to own 2023
right now I think I'm still renting
um but I I here's what I'll say
one never knows when all these projects
are going to come out so you just kind
of do the work when it comes and you
hope that it's good and you just move
forward and
um for everything to be coming out at
once I'm not gonna lie it's a little
overwhelming but it's I'm grateful I'm
grateful and I feel blessed and I feel
you know the this body of work is very
diverse and very different and
um
yeah it's also great because each role
is so different so different yeah it
just shows you what you can do as a
performer well thank you I try but
seriously
um yeah how quickly with this project
you people
um how quickly did you sign on to this
when did you know Eddie and Jonah and
like how much did you know when you got
the script because for me if someone
told me you know all these people are in
it yeah like just where do I go well Kai
was kind of like that I kind of didn't
need to know what the script was about I
was like whatever if they're doing it
I'm doing it
um no but I I did read the story because
that's what I do but um I would say that
Kenny and I are friends he told me he
was doing this project I was like oh
that sounds so good I was living in New
York at the time
and he called and said I really want you
to read this and tell me what you think
and I was like all right cool and I
really liked the idea of putting
together the black family and the Jewish
Family I think it's long overdue it's a
you know it's a it's a contemporary
story there's misunderstanding there's
comedy there's
um there's a lot of side eyes
on the poster too I know I was like wow
I'm really giving side eye on the poster
um
but right these are those uncomfortable
experiences and moments between two
families when there is a marriage right
everyone's kind of jocking for position
wants to be in control the film really
explores cultural practices and how they
can how they can um
create big conflict yeah and it's also
very authentic it's not um like
hollywoodized if you will no there were
cameras everywhere I didn't even know
what was being shot half the time I was
like oh that was on me I'm sorry can we
do that again I gotta go I'm just gonna
say thank you so much oh my gosh thank
you for coming and seriously congrats